thank you
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
just the best day ever it is the best
day ever and so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day from now until
forever
you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof And my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what do I have to do you have to
go to the real world
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the
universe
the choice is
the first one the high heel you have to
want to know okay do it again
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm coming with you okay
[Music]
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Applause]
[Music]
real world that's impossible if this got
out this could be an extremely weird
things for our world
catastrophic
educated Barbie since we were like five
five
no one rests until this doll is back in
a box even if nobody else
humans only have one ending
tears live forever
[Music]
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody get security
[Music]
is Bobby boots if you're still in doubt